he is one of our favorite guests one of
our favorite people he's a four-time Pro
Bowl tight end who is uh here courtesy
of Old Spice he is I guess a much newer
spice Travis Kelce of the Kansas City
Chiefs how are you Travis bridge it is
always a pleasure man one of my favorite
shows the to listen to but also be a
part of Thank You Travis you're not just
saying that are you did you say that to
Dan Patrick when he had you on earlier
did he say no I did not say that the Dan
but don't mention that today Dan's got
some stuff going on over there we're all
just hoping we're praying for him right
now okay Travis I appreciate that
let's start it's very rare how's your
patella doing your patella good yeah
everything's great over here
knock on wood it's it's working like it
should be I've been very thankful that
you know I've been I've been healthy
through the first seven weeks and as we
know football it's it's not always like
that
I know that what what how's your
quarterback I guess I should have just
come straight through the front door
what's going on with your QB Island
right now okay just just being able to
kind of text with him over the weekend
he's excited that he's going to get
better and get back out on the field
sometime hopefully sooner than later but
it's just right now it's just I know
kind of trying to feel out what exactly
his knees feeling like and and then how
fast he can get back to full strength
what a freak accident right I mean have
you ever seen anything like that on a
sneak house oh no i've never looked down
at someone's knee and seen their knee
cap in a different place oh my gosh it
literally did not look like a regular
knee and and that's it that's the
alarming thing is once you see something
like that you just know you kind of just
start hoping and praying that you know
he's he's okay I mean it's one thing to
see a great football player go down like
that but I've been a big fan of Patrick
mahomes as a person man and as a brother
and and to see something like that
happen to someone you're again you care
about your love man it's a it stinks
well you know what I mean it's a fan as
a fan of just football and obviously of
his and and I think I speak for pretty
much everybody even those who
[Music]
not have the Chiefs on their wish list
in the AFC West Travis it's just a
bummer I'm wondering what is it like for
you that's your teammate you know what
he means to the team you know what he
means to the city you know what he means
to you personally and vice versa what do
you think what goes through your mind
when you see that with your own two eyes
out of the blue on Thursday night man
it's a it's a tough feeling I mean
you're you're absolutely drained
immediately immediately it just takes
the life right idea the best football
player and the National Football League
goes down and can't finish a game and
it's a everyone everyone feels that
impact and and Matt Matt Moore did an
unbelievable job of coming through with
excitement with with with a positive
mentality with the mentality they don't
worry we're gonna we're gonna win this
game for them we're gonna get we're
gonna get this ball in the end zone and
we're gonna find a way to come out of
Denver with a win and and that was the
biggest thing is something like that
happens we're an unbelievable player
goes down you just you rely on the
system you rely on your teammates to
keep their composure and not do anything
that that you wouldn't do so you've got
to you know not do anything
uncharacteristically trying to kind of
make up for what we lost and Matt more
than unbelievable job of coming in well
before I move on to Matt Moore last
thing is dude do you or has any film
revealed how it happened what exactly
did occur in that pile Travis no I
didn't see anything and I'm obviously
everyone's jumping on each other at that
point so you really don't know how it
happened or or whether yeah it was just
uh as a freak accident man I've never
heard of anything seen anything like it
especially on a play like a QB sneak you
know a play where I don't really
remember anyone ever getting hurt on a
play like that
and then you know again just to you know
continue on with me just saying when
when as a fan of the sport and a fan of
mahomes etc you know you're bummed but
you also feel robbed certainly with
Aaron Rodgers coming into your house on
a Sunday night football game that
said Matt Moore's story is particularly
fascinating to God was just he was
teaching right
earlier this year Travis that's a yes
and I believe he was a during the during
the draft process last year around like
January or February I believe he was
scouting or he was he was thinking about
getting into that world as NFL scout
which is a crazy turn around I mean well
just when you think your career is over
with you get a call from Andy Reid to
come be a part of the Kansas City Chiefs
and it was funny just having quick
conversations with him in the beginning
of the year saying I was just I was just
sitting on the couch watching your guys
preseason games drinking a beer and now
I'm in the mix like I'm one snap away
and it's absolutely crazy thought
process to even go through but he's been
ready for the moment ever since he's got
here man he's he's a true professional
what he does and and sure enough his
experience shows Travis Kelce here on
the Rich Eisen show all right what's
going on with Old Spice bro what do you
got here what's happening here coming
back with Old Spice videos I've brought
so many products on this on this just
this show alone and this year the
campaign being Old Spice sweat defense
dry spray antiperspirant yeah is the 48
hours of sweat and odor protection I
mean you're getting two full days of
sweat and odor protection then I'm a
stinky smelly guy so I'm throwing it on
just like I'm throwing it on probably
twice a day still but this is a first
for the the regular person the average
person it doesn't stink and sweat and
sweat as much as I do 48 hours of sweat
and odor protection and it's the the the
NFL's sweat defense campaign it's in
every single locker room in the NFL so
it's got to be in yours okay gotcha and
and you could check it out on old
Spice's youtube channel so if I get 47
hours and 30 minutes of sweat protection
Travis do I come find you and ask for
those 30 minutes of sweat protection
back I mean oh yeah I do come right to
me you can come right I put a stamp of
approval on you're getting 48 hours so
late work
now working out like you know I'm a 50
year old man now I've taken up tennis
Travis
I've taken out on the forehand backhand
yes I am oh you're you're in great hands
with this anti dry spray inside
perspiration okay I've because I'll come
looking for you I saw you went back to
school you're like not hiding I'm not
hiding you back you went back to school
this weekend right
did you baby a teen ranked 18th in the
country got one loss to an unbelievable
high Oh state team right now right and
I'm so happy for Coach fickle and the
boys back in Sin City man it's good to
see the Bearcats doing good again how
come no disrespect to the Bearcats how
come you didn't go to Ohio State I'm
sorry the Ohio State did they not come
knocking on your door Travis mr. Ohio
ironically Luke simple when he was at
the Ohio State University recruited me
and my brother and you know that's a
question that I've been meaning to ask
coach Nicholas why I didn't get the
offer but I am I think I had a little
bit to do with I was pretty set on
playing quarterback in and at that point
they had the number one recruiting me in
the nation and terrelle pryor coming to
their school so I I'm pretty sure I was
just I was just too far down what do you
mean you were set on playing quarterback
what are you talking about I went to the
University of Cincinnati to play
quarterback okay I had no intentions of
moving to tight end until my junior year
of college so what happened what what
what finally made you give in Travis um
I think it was it had a little bit to do
with the situation at hand in terms of
we already had a starting quarterback
Zach culeros who was actually my
roommate for about three or four years
there and he he was a dual threat guy I
was I was also a dual threat guys in
terms of being able to run the ball more
so than I could pass it anyways but I
knew I wasn't gonna get on the field any
time soon playing quarterback so it was
it was it was you to keep sitting it out
and then hope that I can win the job my
senior year or just make the transition
to tie it in and get out get out there
on the field and have some fun playing
football yeah I just started while you
gave that answer because I'm a
quick typer I went to the old I went to
the old pro football reference page you
do not have a career passing attempt in
the National Football League it does not
appear is that true well thank gosh they
didn't jot down the interception I threw
here it is no I just saw that I just saw
it
you're over one with one pick oh come on
for one just completed the wrong no no
that's what it is so you did throw a
pick is do cheat I'm sorry I didn't mean
a walk in in that one oh good I'll
probably never throw another pass again
but come on come on that's what history
is it was it was a quick it was a quick
kind of learning experience I threw the
pick and Alex Smith comes up to me and
shrug the shoulders said sorry it was it
was it was probably a 50 60 yard throw
downfield and I think as Landry Jones
okay
I forget who picked it but do you
remember who you were targeting who are
you targeting who talked gardening
DeMarcus Robinson just running scot-free
down the sideline so what are you hung
it up there did you hang it dad you know
what I had the gloves Nike does an
unbelievable job of really making the
gloves sticky oh and in the glove it
kind of got caught as I threw it so it
didn't go down the sideline I went kind
of more over the middle of the field and
and yeah that was it was a pretty easy
pick actually Alex Smith comes over to
me since it was so far downfield he's
just shrugged his shoulders and that's
like a part he was a good teammate man
he's always a son you know says that
sunny disposition okay before I let you
go I saw you met Randy Reed I saw you
met Andy's brother Randy Steven coach
Reed had such an unbelievable brother
right the biggest best thing I got from
his that you never know when you're
gonna turn your ankle you know so while
you always got a speck right
you always got a SPAD even even when
you're just walking around and in life
but it wasn't odd that make sure you
take care of those ankle it wasn't odd
that he just tried to sell you on a boat
out of the blue Travis that didn't
strike you as odd no I mean I grabbed
jet skis from him
the year before and he gave me quite a
that was I was I was actually intrigued
when he came to me with the boat idea
okay yeah and he just made himself at
home I mean we're looking at the video
right now just talking to all sorts of
offensive linemen getting down there and
showing how to start a snap I we're
taking a look at it looks like he was a
difference maker when it all came down
to it you know his perspective was was
definitely appreciated
[Music]
Travis you the best man we'll chat soon
okay thank you brother
I appreciate you always finding time man
have a good one you got it at t kelsey
on twitter at killa trav on instagram
check everything out with Old Spice on
its YouTube channel today for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app